if we can just rewind a little bit to uh
the DARPA robotics challenge in 2015 I
think which was for people who are
familiar with the DARPA challenges
it uh was first with autonomous vehicles
and there's a lot of interesting
challenges around that and the DARPA
robotics challenges when uh humanoid
robots were tasked to do all kinds of
uh you know manipulation walking driving
a car all these kinds of challenges with
if I remember correctly sort of
some slight capability to communicate
with humans but uh the communication was
very poor so basically has to be almost
entirely autonomous you can have periods
where the communication was entirely
interrupted and the robot had to be able
to proceed yeah but you could provide
some high level guidance to the robot
basically load low bandwidth
Communications yeah to steer it I
watched that challenge with kind of
tears in my eyes eating popcorn
but I wasn't personally losing uh you
know hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars and many years of incredible
hard work by some of the most brilliant
roboticists in the world so that was why
the tragic was why tears came so anyway
what have you uh just looking back to
that time what have you learned from
that experience
I mean maybe if you could describe what
it was uh sort of to set up for people
who haven't seen it well so there was a
contest where a bunch of different
um robots were asked to do a series of
tasks uh some of those that you
mentioned drive a vehicle get out open a
door go identify a valve shut a valve
use a tool to maybe cut a hole in
um a surface and then crawl over some
stairs and maybe some rough Terrain
so it was
the idea was have a general purpose
robot that could do lots of different
things
it had to be mobility and manipulation
on board perception
and there was a contest uh which DARPA
likes at the time was running sort of
follow-on to the the Grand Challenge
which was let's let's try to push
vehicle autonomy along right they they
encourage people to build autonomous
cars so they're trying to basically push
an industry forward and
um
uh we were asked our role in this was to
build
um a humanoid at the time it was our
sort of first generation Atlas robot
and we built maybe 10 of them I don't
remember the exact number
and DARPA distributed those to various
teams
um that sort of won a contest showed
that they could you know program these
robots and then use them to compete
against each other and then other robots
were introduced as well some teams built
their own robots Carnegie
um melon for example built their own
robot and uh and all these robots
competed to see who could sort of get
through this this maze or the fastest
and again I think the purpose was to
kind of push the whole industry forward
we provided the robot and some baseline
software but we didn't we didn't
actually compete as a participant where
we were trying to uh you know Drive the
robot through this maze we were just
trying to support the other teams
it was humbling because it was it was
really a hard task and honestly the
robots the tears were because mostly the
robots didn't do it you know they fell
down
you know repeatedly
um it was hard to get through this
contest uh you know some did and and you
know they were rewarded and won
but it was humbling because of just how
hard these tasks weren't all that hard a
person could have done it very easily
but it was really hard to get the robots
to do it you know the general nature of
it the the variety of it the variety and
also that I don't know if the tasks were
sort of the task in themselves help us
understand what is difficult and what is
not I don't know if that was obvious
before the contest was designed so you
kind of tried to figure that out and I
think Atlas is really a general robot
platform and it's perhaps not best
suited for the specific tasks of that
contest like for just for example
probably the hardest task is not the
driving of the car but getting in and
out of the car and Atlas probably you
know if you were to design a robot that
can get into the car easily and get out
easily you probably would not make Atlas
with that particular car yeah the robot
was a little bit big to get in and out
of that car right it doesn't fit yeah
this is the curse of a general purpose
robot that they're not perfect at any
one thing
but they might be able to do a wide
variety of things and and that is
that is the goal at the end of the day
you know I think we all want to build
general purpose robots that can be used
for lots of different activities
but it's hard and
um and the wisdom in in building
successful robots up until this point
have been go build a robot for a
specific task and it'll do it very well
and as long as you control that
environment it'll operate perfectly but
but robots need to be able to deal with
uncertainty if they're going to be
useful to us in the future
they need to be able to deal with
unexpected uh situations and that's sort
of the goal of a general purpose or
multi-purpose robot
and that's just darn hard and so some of
you know there's these curious little
failures like I remember one of the a
robot you know the first the first time
you start to try to push on the world
with a robot you you forget that the
world pushes back and and will push you
over if you're not ready for it and the
robot you know reached to grab the door
handle I think it missed the grasp of
the door handle was expecting that its
hand was on the door handle and so when
it tried to turn the knob it just threw
itself over it didn't realize oh I had
missed the door handle I didn't have I
didn't I was expecting a force back from
the door it wasn't there and then I lost
my balance so these little simple things
that you and I would take totally for
granted and deal with the robots don't
know how to deal with yet and so you
have to start to deal with all of those
uh circumstances well I think a lot of
us experience this in uh even when sober
but drunk too uh sort of you pick up a
thing and expect it to be
what is it heavy and it turns out to be
light yeah oh yeah and then so the same
and I'm sure if your depth perception
for whatever reason is screwed up if
you're if you're drunk or some other
reason and then you think you're putting
your hand on the table and you miss it I
mean it's the same kind of situation
yeah but
there's why you need to be able to
predict forward just a little bit and so
that's where this model predictive
control stuff comes in predict forward
what you think is going to happen
and then if and if that does happen
you're in good shape if something else
happens you better start predicting
again so if we like re-re uh regenerate
a plan yeah when you don't I mean that
um that also requires a very uh fast
feedback loop of updating
what your prediction how it matches to
the actual real world
yeah those things have to run pretty
quickly what's the challenge of running
things pretty quickly a thousand Hertz
of acting and sensing
quickly you know there's a few different
layers of that you you want at the
lowest level you like to run things
typically at around a thousand Hertz
which means that you know at each joint
of the robot you're measuring position
or force and then trying to control your
actuator whether it's a hydraulic or
electric motor trying to control the
force coming out of that actuator and
you want to do that really fast
something like a thousand Hertz and that
means you can't have too much
calculation going on at that joint
um but that's pretty manageable these
days and it's fairly common
and then there's another layer that
you're probably calculating you know
maybe at 100 Hertz maybe 10 times slower
which is now starting to look at the
overall body motion and thinking about
the the larger physics of of the uh of
the robot
um and then there's yet another loop
that's probably happening a little bit
slower which is where you start to bring
you know your perception and your vision
and things like that and so you need to
run all of these Loops sort of
simultaneously you do have to manage
your your computer time so that you can
squeeze in all the calculations you need
in real time in a very consistent way
and the amount of calculation we can do
is increasing as computers get better
which means we can start to do more
sophisticated calculations I can have a
more complex model
doing my forward prediction
and and that might allow me to do even
better predictions as I as I get better
and better and and it used to be again
we had
you know 10 years ago
we had to have pretty simple models
that we were running you know at those
fast rates because the computers weren't
as capable about calculating forward
with a sophisticated model but as as
computation gets better we can we can do
more of that